abone ol
bu Merhaba herkese değil mi ya Bence
yorulduğumuz artık çünkü gerçekten
nöronlar deli gibi çalışıyor Saatlerdir
o kadar güzel insanı o kadar güzel
şeyler anlattı ki ben yoruldum Umarım bu
on yedi buçukta ki de iyi geçiririz
şimdi Gökhan çok iyi anlattı Teşekkür
ederim ama o kadar değil aslında ben
müteşebbis im yıllardır girişimcilikle
uğraşıyorum Eğer sunumun gelirse yavaş
yavaş başlayacağız Biz fikir of you diye
bir şey konuşacağız İngilizce için özür
dilerim bu benim Muhtemelen meslek
hastalığı Onu düzeltmeye çalışıyorum
Umarım bir gün bunu başaracağım benim
için gençlik de
da gelecek Demek ki videonun arkasına 3.
gereği de bağladım girişimcilik demek
dolayı 3 ile alakalı bir toplam fotoğraf
konuşalım istiyorum Ama önce biraz
kendimden bahsedeyim size Ben orta
gelirli bir ailenin tek çocuğu babam
devlet memuru annem ev hanımı ve
Ankara'da doğdum Şu hiç bir avantajı yok
Aslında bugün bu kırmızı nokta üzerinde
bu benim dördüncü tedex konuşmam buraya
gelebilmek için aslında bana yaratılan
tek şey annemin ve babamın yıllarca
kendilerinden kesip beni üniversitede
okumaları için yaptıkları özverili Ondan
sonra sağ artık bana kalmıştı ve kendi
işimi kurmak için Turkcell düğününe
verdik Okulda falan yaptığımız stajlar
sonrası Şunu fark ettim ki ben büyük
denizlerde yüzen yiyeceğim kendi işini
yapmam lazım ama sermaye ihtiyacım var
onun içinde bir hikayem var Belki hikaye
hızlıca anlatmam lazım ama
bu açmayalım diye aklımdan geçiyordu ama
şimdi anlatmam gerektiğini hissediyorum
bir kahve markasının lansmanı için
üniversite kampüsünün etkinlik
yapacaktık ve mavi Üniversitesi gidip
izin almak için üniversite kirasını
salon kirasını ödeyebilmek için bir para
ihtiyacımız oldu o zaman ki ortam bana
Ben ona baktım ve genel sekreteri Ya
kusura bakmayın şu anda bizim öyle bir
paramız yok Ozan Biz istedik ve çıktık
sonra akşam alibo kahve markasında şunu
söylememiz gerekiyordu ya biz
yapamıyoruz Bu iş için paramız yok
Dolayısıyla ilk girişimci Hikayemiz
başarısızlıkla sonuçlanacak the ama
televolede o zamanlar Televole diye bir
program vardı mm bir yılından
bahsediyorum Tarkan rumelihisarı'nda
Kuzu Kuzu isimli bir albümünün sahne
şovunu yapıyor ve elinde dansöz değildir
var her dem bana baktı Ben de hayır
yapmam
İyi o zaman dedi Sen arayacaksın
edeceksek yapamıyoruz ya da buna karar
vereceğiz ve yarın gideceğiz bir zincir
bulacağız bu zillerden satın alacağız
4000 tane koltuk hesabı yaptık ya gidip
ozellileri almak zorunda kalkamaz indir
alacaklarımız da olmadığı için Erdem'in
Şahin marka arabası ruhsatını zinciri
amcaya emanet ettik zil camcıdan siyah
poşetler içerisinde 4000 tane zili
sırtımızda taşıdık ve akşam bir kısmını
üretmekte zorunda kaldık bayağı
bildiğiniz daha sözlerin eline takımı
oynadığı zillerle Tarkan Aslında sahne
şovunu yaparken girişimcinin o eksik
kalan fotoğraftaki eksik kalan bileşeni
bulma sihriyle sahnenin karşısına kamera
döndüğünde alkış tutan değil zillionaire
şirketin insanlar olmasını sadece oradan
kazandığımız parayla ya ilk girişimcilik
hikayesi başladı tabii böyle keyifli
anlattım ama böyle olmadı fakültemizin
mı geldi bizsiz İngilizce çekmeden bunun
için mezun ettik dedi Bi zp Çünkü biz
işportacılık yapıyorduk o sırada Nuran
yenge annemi aradım dedi ki senin olan
koku oldu falan staj yapıyordu orada
çalışacaksınız is atarken gördüm
televizyonda Çünkü aynı telefonu girip
müteşebbis çocuklar diye bir haber
yapmıştı Dolayısıyla sana hikayenin bir
kısmı size yaşattıkları acılarla
Hatırlamıyor Ben bunu 2010 yılında Ender
girişinizi seçildim böyle Uluslararası
bir sürü başarılı iş insanı geldi ve
Jülide bizim işimizi dinledi ilk sarmayı
nereden bulduğumuzu sordular Ali Koç da
var Yüreğimin içinde ve Ali beyin
bildiği bir hikaye olduğu için bence
Anlat Başka türlü çıkamazsın bu sorun
içinden dedi ve anlatmak zorunda kaldım
sekiz kişiden 6'sı kalkıp alkışladık Tan
sonra o gün bugündür bu hikayeyi o güne
kadar oturarak anlattım bu hikayeyi
Bir tane de gururla anlatmaya başladım
ve bunun Aslında Türkiyedeki
girişimcilik ekosisteminin bugünkü O
süslü antrenörler Angel investoren falan
olduğu dönemin olmadığı zamanlarda belki
de tek sermaye erişim metodu olarak
kullanıldığı bir dönemden Geliyorum
şimdi bugün Sizler de bir gün girişimci
olmaya karar verirseniz ki bu sunumun
sonunda amacım bu sonunda üç kişiyi
girişimci yapmak için motive edebilmiş
olmaz Sadece üç kişi yeter bana şimdi
Aslında Amerika'da dört tane adam bütün
Amerika'yı değiştirdi Biraz sonra
konuşacağız bize bir de ben stresim seni
girişimcilik dışında da birçok gelecek
uygun görüsü yapan olumlu gelecek
tasviri yapan insan gibi ben de aslında
hepimiz için pozitif olumlu bir gelecek
tasarlamaya ve bu insanların farkındalık
seviyesini yükseltecek şekilde onları
anlatmaya ve birlikte gençlik riskler
diye bir ekiple ve
bu işler Derneği ve Birds To Say the
Society de görev olarak üzerine
sorumluluk olarak almış ve çalışıyor
vaziyetteyim ev yaptığım işler bunlar
aslında milyonları milyonlarca genci bir
yerden bir yere hareket ettirebilmesi
tecrübe ettim şimdi üniversite
kampüslerinde böyle sıra dışı
konteynırlardan mağazalar yapmaya
başladım bu aralar bir banka kurmaya
çalışıyorum gençlik Bankası sadece
gençlerin kullanacağı bankacılık
hizmetleri bir araya getiren tamamen
ücretsiz Hatta onları bir sürü fayda
veren bir banka kurmaya çalışıyor be
Spor Kulübü var o yolu tadında en sporla
ilgilenenler imiz var mı bilmiyorum ama
mesela bu iyi bir örnek olabilir final
maçı geçtiğimizi Türkiye Şampiyonu oldu
ve final maçında 13 bin kişinin bilet
vererek gelip seyrettiği beş tane genç
çocuğun bilgisayar başında karşı tatil
beşgen Çocuğa karşı
he he müsabaka içerisinde görev aldığı
bir spor dalından bahsediyoruz ter yoksa
spor mudur Konuşmuyorsan spor mudur kupa
verilir mi vesaire Bu da son işim
üniversite kampüsünün içerisinde yut
altında gençlerin tek başına
kalabilecekleri dosya düşünecekler
üretebilecek leri Yurtlar yapmaya
çalışıyor Niye böyle uğraşıyor niye her
şeyin gençlikte alakalı adına
youtholding dedim Onun altında gençlerin
bir sürü ihtiyacım birleştirmeye
çalışıyorum Çünkü asla Türkiye çok genç
bir nüfusa sahip veya Biz 5 deposunu
doğru yönlendirme Seker onları akl-ı
Selim bir şekilde düşünmeye sevk
edemezsek üretmeye sevk edemezse kalsın
elimize çok büyük bir saatli bomba mız
var Dolayısıyla karınca kararınca kendi
yarattığım inandım Beykoz sistemi hala
sahiplenmeye devam ediyorum şimdi
gençler yılda 53 milyar TL para
harcıyorlar bu ülkede ve bunu
harcıyorlar biriktir mi yor lar üretime
dönmüyor tamamen tüketim toplumu olarak
Hayatımıza devam ediyoruz Her yıl
bu Amasya Türkiye'de nüfusumuzun 169 yaş
altı Annelerimizin babalarımızın satın
alma kararlarını artık Bizler vermeye
başladı birçok marka sizde ne
beyinlerine erişebilmek için ya da
evdeki size erişebilmek için çocuğunuza
iletişim yapmaya çalışıyor çamaşır
makinesi kararların yüz 35'ini bu gerçek
araştırması 135'in artık genç veriyormuş
evdeki Çünkü araştırma yetenekleri daha
kuvvetli dijital erişim kompleksin
karşılaşma yetenekleri daha kuvvetli
aynı zamanda geleceğin yetenek grubu
yani eğer o insanlarla bir şey
yapacaklarsa gençlere gidiyor Hadi
onları dokunmayı onları kazanmaya
çalışıyor ya Tabii ki siyaseten de
stratejik olarak da genç nüfuslu ülkenin
geleceği demek onları doğru
şekillendirmek ve kendi ideolojileri ile
onlara bir yön verebilmek için
çabalıyorlar Peki aynı zamanda gençler
geleceğin tüketicileri Yani bugün 20
yaşında bir gencin zaman kıldığı bir
kahve markasında çevirebilirsiniz
Bu bir daha diğer kahve markasını kahve
sıcak sütlü şekerli geliyor olabilir ve
simit etmeyebilir diğer kahramankazan
geçmeli doğası bugünden gençleri
kazanmak gibi dertleri var Fakat son
dönemlerde şunu hissetmeye üç yıldır
falan şunu hissetmeye başladım Bazı
insanların söyledikleriyle bunu fark
etmeye başladım ve bunun farkındalığını
Bu salonda da dahil olmak üzere Herkese
anlatmaya çalışıyorum yaratmaya
çalışıyorum O da Aslında her birimiz bir
ürüne dönüşmüş vaziyetteyiz bir insan
ürüne dönüşebilmesi için aslında yeter
şart nedir bam Pro süper alıcısının
olması bir insanın alıcısı nasıl
olabilir bir ev seçimi Peki başka sosyal
medya
ve hızlı gideyim mi datası satılıyor
olabilir Bir insanın Aslında ve bunu
sağlamak içinde size bir sürü ücretsiz
Servis veriyor ve dünyadaki yeni
şirketler ne ücretsiz servisler veriyor
çünkü çıkıyor diyor ki biliyoruz onların
sorgusu solfrid an Yürek oradaki eğer
diyor Onlar hizmetleri ücretsiz
kullanıyorsanız artık ürün Sizsiniz
Çünkü siz spotify'a para vermiyorsanız
Instagram'a Tikko para vermiyorsanız ya
da kullandığınız bir sürü uygulamaya
sizi güzelleştirecek filtreleri falan
para vermeden onları kullanıyorsanız ya
da gece uyut uyut anlamda sizin uyku
saygımızı uyku dön gününüzü ölçecek bir
uygulamaya para vermedi onu
kullanıyorsanız olan bir şey vermeniz
lazım O şirketin para kazanması için bir
şeyinizi teslim etmiş olmanız lazım o da
veriniz ve buna çıkacak söylüyorlar
Aslında Hepimizin datası hepimizin
verisi o dijital katman üzerinden
satılık
bu katman açalım birazcık khatta Deniz
Hoca Biraz önce söyledi Aslında sadece
bizim dediğimizi topluyor güzel bir şey
satmaya çalışıyorlar aynı zamanda bizi
Manipüle etmeye çalışıyor çünkü
İngiltere'de brexit de Amerika'da
seçimlerde Cambridge analytica skandalı
ile ortaya çıkan bir şekilde Facebook
Aslında hepimizin tarafsız nötr
fikirleri olan insanların siyasi
fikirlerini değiştirip onları
yönlendirip istedikleri yöne oy
verebilecek bir Algoritma üzerinde
operasyon yapmış bu Sonradan çıktı
biliyorsunuz akıl röportaja çıktı
mahkemede mahkeme huzurunda da bayağı
zor zamanlar yaşadık Çünkü aslında
hepimiz elinizdeki O şu anda sadece
elinizdeki ya da Kolumuzdaki ya da
masamızın üzerindeki bilgisayarlarla
data üretip duruyoruz ayak izleri bi
parmak izleri bırakıp duruyoruz İyiler
atıyoruz tweetler atıyoruz bir şeyler
seyrediyoruz arkadaşlarımızla WhatsApp
üzerin
ne yaşıyoruz vesaire dünyadaki aşağıda 8
milyar insanın yüzde 57'si internet
kullanıcısı yani 657 sinin dijital
Dünyası var yani fiziki olarak sabah
uyandı yatağımızda kalktık yürüdük bir
yere gittik Bu fiziksel aktivitenin
hiçbirinden da toplanamıyor şu anda Ama
uyandık dişinizi fırçalamadan
telefonunuzu elinize aldık ve hemen
orada bir işlem yaptık dolayısı artık
bir yere data vermeye başladık bizim
alışkanlıklarımızı tercihlerimizi öğret
onlara öğretmeye başladık ve bunlar
hepsi birbiriyle 15 üzerinden bira
üzerinden bağlandığında bizim dijital
DNA mızı çıkartma yoluna doğru gitmeye
başlamış Vaziyet Peki bunu niye
yapıyorlar Bunlar biraz Medya kanulasyon
reklam gösterecekler diye başladılar
yani Facebook size niye bedava yerden
arada reklamlar görünecekti yerlerden
ama seni çok kadar masum değil Çünkü
Facebook Instagram'ı satın aldı
WhatsApp'ı satın aldı bunların üçünü
birleştirip arka tarafta sizin arama
motoru ruhlu a
bu mallarınızla birleştirdi size bir gün
yolda yürürken oradaki tenis kursu nun
bilgisini vermek kadar masum ama nereden
haberdar oldu ya benim tenis ile alakalı
bir şey araştırıldığı ndan derken
karşınıza çıkan reklam kadar masum değil
Niye masum olmadığında konuşacağız
Aslında Medya kanalları yavaş yavaş like
prosesleri yani hayat hayatımızdaki
bütün fiillere birer start-up ortaya
çıkmaya başladı dinlemek yürümek okumak
koşmak bak uyumak seyretmek mesajlaşmak
sohbet etmek sosyalleşmek gibi herşeyin
karşında bir eşlikçi ortaya çıkmaya
başladı ki bu ne Niye böyle bir şey
yapıyorlar Daha tembel olun diye artık
bütün katmanlar size elinizden o
yorulacağız bunun için çaba sarf etmeniz
gereken fiilleri alıp Ben senin yanına
yapacağım bunu basitleştiren bunu
kolaylaştıracağını değil size Birlik
söylüyor ve 13 tarihinde başka bir poz
özgürlük alıyor web
da işte Burada mesela bir örnekle
görebiliriz benim bulduğum vardı sonra
mikrobloglar çıktı ve tweet atmaya
başladım Sonra Instagram'da sadece bir
kare fotoğraf koyarak ona iki üç tane
filtre koyarak kendini ifade etmeyi
öğrendim sonra sinepçet çıktı o kadar
düşünmene gerek yok çünkü
instagramdakiler fosforlu gibi birikiyor
bas uçsun gitsin silinsin Bir daha da
kimse görmesinler başladı ve yavaş yavaş
daha da tembel hale gelmeye başladık en
son şunu yaşamaya başladı Benim
telefonda bir sorun oldu sabah düşürdüm
için Gökhan'ın telefonunu kullanıyorum
bu bozkont ler hayatımıza girdi ve Siri
Bana Bir Masal Anlatır mısın olsun
Bu bir tekerleme okur musun Tamam işte
bu takatukaları takatukacıya
takatukalatmaya götür Takatukacı
takatukaları al da gel o da 68 tane Siri
developer yazılımcısı niçin Türkiye'de
birisi çıksın siri'yi şaklaban gibi
kullansın diye ona masal anlatırsın ona
tekerleme okusun diye yazmış olabilir
amacı ne olabilir bizim duygusal bağ
kurmak değil mi bize daha arkadaş
canlısı göstermek istediğim bizimle daha
fazla iletişim kurmasını sağlamak ona
daha fazla başvurmamız onu bir body gibi
bir yakın arkadaş gibi konumlandırma
mızı sağlamak istiyor Ee keşke sadece
konu Siri olsa Çünkü şu anda sazlarla
bir da toplaya biliyoruz ama hayatınızda
şu an a**** olan her
bir düşünün yani ayakkabılarımız Gözümüz
geleceğimiz çorabı mız köpeğinizin
tasması evden içeri girerken
kullandığımız anahtarımız kapı kolumuz
her şeyi a**** hiçbir akımı değil ve
onların üstüne zaten üretemiyor olan
hiçbiri sizi takip eden Yollar hiç bir
merkeze sizinle alakalı bir information
bir bilgi veremiyor dolayı sizin
hayatınızı belli kısımları boşlukta
oradaki da bezle boşlukta oradaki
veritabanında sizin Bazı yerlerde
kayıtlarınız var onları toplamaları
lazım navigasyonda Nereden Nereye
gittiğinizi anlıyor ama arabanın
içerisindeki koltukta heyecanlandın mı
bilmiyor Çünkü arabanın koltuğunuz
akıllı değil Build Dolayısıyla yapmaya
çalıştıkları şey aslında
bu inanca buradayken çok detayına girmek
bana düşmez Ama insanların vücutları
içerisine girecek hale gelene kadar bu
mikroçipleri işte silikonlu hale
getirmek insanın nöronlarına bağlanacak
ne rolling isimli o sinir ağlarına
bağlanacak hale getirmeye kadar Aslında
teknoloji hedefi bu uzaktan sinema ile
başlayan 20 metre ilerde seyrettiğimiz
teknoloji içerik yavaş yavaş
televizyonla salonlarımızda girdi
bilgisayarlarla 40 santime yaklaştı
telefonlarla 20 santime yaklaştım İnik
mi denemeye Deniz hazır olmadığımız için
geri çektiler Google asla gözümüze bir
santime geldi şimdi lenslerle Aslında
gözümüze koymaya çalışıyorlar ama bunun
hepsi birer alıştırma asla hiçbirine
gerek yok input dönen yani içerik denen
ve girdi denen şey aslında bir dışarıdan
bizim Duyu organlarımızı geçerek
ulaşması gereken bir şey değil mi
o çocukları bir çift ve asla hepsini
çözebilirler ve bunun çalışmaları
yapılıyor bugün ve bütün şirketlerde
birbirlerini teknoloji konusunda
yarışarak geçmeye çalışıyor Loreal diyor
ki ben artık birkaç konuşun elektronik
Show'a Katılıyor hem teknoloji şirketi
ya da hızlı geçeceğim ya da Amazon
çıkıyor evlerinize bir araya otur ürün
bir nesnelerin interneti koyuyor ve
tuvalet kağıdından kahvenize Kaya kadar
Her şey ondan istiyorsun yada Google bir
araba yapıyor seyahatlerin hepsini
kaydetmek istiyor ve siz direksiyon
Tutmayın yola bakmayın ve Google
içeriklerini seyredin o içerideki enter
Diamond sisteminde daha fazla süreyi
Google ekranlarını beni istiyor ve son
saniye daha çok anlatacağım şey var ama
Toparlamam lazım nereye gidiyoruz
biliyor musunuz hepimiz tüketen
da birer prodaks
bu ve amacımız Bunun farkına varıp
üretici hale dönüşmek olmalı bunun
içinde her Birinizin kendi ilgi alanıyla
kendi dünyada gördüğü fırsatı öpüştürüp
bir iş fikri hayata geçirme ihtiyacı var
Çünkü gelecek girişimcilerin yarattığı
yeni şirketlerde ve Bugün artık
ülkelerin hiçbir manasını kalmayacağı
bir dönemini ülke 20 diyeceğiniz Ama
fakat Facebook Amazon Google Apple gibi
şirketlerin yeni ülkeler olacağı bir
dönemi karşılamaya Hazırlanıyoruz Siz de
o dönemin vatandaşları dijital
vatandaşlar olacaksınız ve tüketmeye
onların söylediklerini yapmaya devam
edeceksiniz Eğer bunun farkına varıp o
şirketleri Kuran Türkler olmazsa Çok
teşekkürler sağlar